on pensait qu'ils avaient un mépris du
fait de leur condition psychologique at
on pensé qu'elles ont été méprisés que
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas fait qu'en
cas de leur situation
je pense oui il y avait un côté bon
débarras comme on donne un animal à
garder avec elle c'est vrai que ça
fonctionne pas quoi et c'est elle ne
sont pas considérés comme des cette fois
ci c'est ça l'état devrait investir
davantage de ressources pour les
personnes les plus vulnérables et on
connaît peu leur nom en fait c'est
pourquoi je trouve que c'est très bien
leur montrer leur image c'est qu'on
connaît d'autres victimes qui la met l
on les connaît peut on connaître leurs
disparus de l'yonne c'était cette jeune
fille de la dass qui était en plus
handicapé mental est le plus vulnérable
xavi ce sont des vies qui sont déroulés
intégralement dans la barbarie là le
malheur et la malédiction basse et c'est
à ce moment qu'on se demande d'ailleurs
comment ça peut exister se sont laissés
pour contre dans mes sincères nous
écarter du débat quant aux moi
effectivement karl zéro qui qui qui
s'engagera avec se manifestent on nous
dit qu'un enfant sur 5 2 quai est
victime de pédocriminalité on peut
imaginer que quand on on concentre
effectivement le regard plus
particulièrement sur des enfants de la
dass sur des enfants
je veux dire le taux doit être
certainement plus élevé parce qu'ils
sont pas encadrées parce que on fait
moins attention à eux deux c'est vrai
qu'on se dit cette société qui se dit
civilisé
de qui parlez droits de l'homme qui
décrètent des droits de l'enfance qui
estime que nous sommes quand même
meilleure que beaucoup d'autres on a
quand même beaucoup pas faire quoi
surtout que karim n'est rien même pas
terrible quoi rime sur le schéma il ya
un fléau là mais carrick donc qu'il
faudrait koné honte près une raison les
enfants les enfants ne peuvent pas
mettre de pression sur les tailles
peuvent pas manifester et le jour ils
peuvent descendre dans la rue si déjà
43e et